let's say i break my arm and it goes in
a cast what happens nine months later
six months later and then they take the
cast off
atrophied
uh arm is atrophied i'm looking out my
window you can't see but there's some
wet trees behind me and they're blowing
in the wind if those trees were planted
in an environment where there was no
wind
they would grow to a certain height and
they would fall over it took the
scientists for a while to figure this
out when they were putting trees in
biodomes because they kept happening
didn't matter what kind but there was no
resilience telling the tree to build you
know gross strong roots deep into the
ground and root properly right
this isn't just human physiology
this is
all living beings if we do not have
challenge that's the end right if you
just sit and do nothing if i don't work
out if i don't work out my mind if i
don't if i don't take on challenge in
these areas you get soft and next thing
you know something's gonna happen and
you're gonna freeze up and not be able
to handle it shut down